One franchise that's been the butt of Rick
and Morty jokes time and time again has been
Marvel.
From Hulk references to Avengers jokes, here’s
all the times Rick and Morty poked fun at
Marvel.
In the season two episode "Total Rickall,"
the Smith family finds themselves plagued
by an interstellar parasite that has the ability
to implant false memories into its hosts.
Each time they have a flashback, a new parasite
joins their midst in the form of a wacky character.
"Wait.
Don't leave without letting Photographer Raptor
take a picture."
In one such dubious memory, the family, along
with their friend Mr. Poopybutthole, is seen
leaving a musical play based on the life of
the Hulk.
They seem pretty excited about the play, and
Jerry is even wearing a pair of fake Hulk
hands.
This is actually a two-for-one reference that
not only gives a nod to the big green guy
but also seems to be an allusion to the real,
disastrous Spider-Man Broadway musical that
injured several stunt performers starting
back in 2010.
A number of these injuries were life-threatening,
and the play experienced a range of other
calamities.
With a price tag of $75 million dollars, Spider-Man:
Turn Off the Dark is the most expensive Broadway
musical ever made, and even though it holds
the Broadway box office record for single-week
sales, taking in $2.9 million over a span
of nine performances, it still lost nearly
$60 million.
In a show with as rabid a fanbase as Rick
and Morty, it's hard to pick any single episode
as a "fan favorite," but two that stand out
are the Interdimensional Cable anthologies.
In the second installment, we're briefly introduced
to Octopus-Man as he somewhat nonsensically
gets into a car with a mysterious driver bearing
a scar across his face.
Claiming to be a marine biologist who was
bitten by an octopus which thereby turned
him into a half-human, half-octopus Octopus-Man
is obviously a riff on Spider-Man.
But while Spidey is a good guy, Octopus-Man
claims to "save people," which basically translates
to him stabbing random people on the street.
So maybe he's really more akin to Spider-Man's
nemesis, Dr. Octopus?
Or maybe in an episode as openly nutty as
this particular one, it's best not to dig
too deep for logic.
"Well Summer, maybe people that create things
aren't concerned with your delicate sensibilities,
you know?"
When Rick and Morty find themselves on the
Purge Planet in season two's "Look Who's Purging
Now," a moment comes when it seems like they're
cornered once and for all.
Then Rick's earlier message to Summer pays
off, and suddenly, Rick and Morty are decked
out in a pair of battle suits that seem suspiciously
similar to those worn by Iron Man and War
Machine.
Not only do these suits come packed with a
seemingly endless series of gadgets used for
attacking an adversary in every way imaginable,
and not only are their wearers practically
invincible, but even the delivery method is
strikingly similar to something Tony Stark
would have designed.
"Morty, time to purge."
The real kicker is the song that plays when
the suits are first activated "Feels Good"
by the R&B group Tony!
Toni!
Toné!
If that's not a sneaky Tony Stark reference,
we don't know what is.
In the show's third season, we're introduced
to the Vindicators, a team of oddball superheroes
that are about as obvious a knockoff of the
Avengers as it gets.
"Rick.
Is that the Vindibeacon?
We're being called to assemble by the Vindicators!"
"I refuse to answer a literal call to adventure,
Morty, let it go to voicemail."
First of all, there's the name, as "vindicate"
and "avenge" are basically synonyms.
Then there are the two groups' symbols, because
when you turn the Vindicators' symbol upside
down, it looks suspiciously similar to that
of the Avengers.
The story of the Vindicators is in itself
extremely Avengery.
We meet the team in "Vindicators 3: The Return
of Worldender," in which it's made clear that
there was a first Vindicator team-up that
included Rick and Morty, as well as a second
one they skipped for reasons that remain vague.
"This article says the reason we weren't involved
was 'personality conflicts.'"
Could this be a reference to the second Avengers
film, Age of Ultron, which many agree was
one of the lesser MCU installments?
At one point, Rick also explicitly refers
to Morty's Vindicators "phase," and as we
all know, the MCU releases are broken up into
a series of phases.
As the episode "Vindicators 3: The Return
of Worldender" makes blatantly clear, said
superhero group has assembled to do battle
against a being called Worldender.
Little is known about the villain, other than
the fact that he possesses great power and
a taste for genocide.
"Vindicators, Worldender is back, and this
time, he's out to end more than worlds."
Sound like anyone familiar?
This is almost certainly a teasing rip-off
of Thanos or Galactus or maybe even both.
He's the cliché mega-villain who's supposedly
unstoppable unless facing the combined might
of the uh, the Vindicators.
His on-the-nose name also seems to point out
how tired audiences are becoming of these
over-the-top baddies.
If Worldender is supposed to be some kind
of Thanos-style enemy who verges on invulnerability,
Rick and Morty sticks its tongue out at this
concept once again by revealing that Rick
has effortlessly defeated him off-screen while
blackout drunk.
"No offense, but I've always suspected that
a lot of what you do in a year could be knocked
out in a couple of hours."
Among the most popular of the MCU's leading
characters is Star-Lord, leader of the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Played by one of the most beloved superstars
in Hollywood, Star-Lord is known for his charm,
good looks, humor, and bravery.
His courage has been instrumental in saving
the galaxy on multiple occasions, even if
his lack of self-control did directly result
in the Thanos snap, which erased half of all
the life in the universe.
But that's a different conversation.
In any case, Star-Lord got the Rick and Morty
treatment in "Vindicators 3: The Return of
Worldender" with the appearance of Vindicators
member Vance Maximus, Renegade Starsoldier,
voiced by the hilarious Christian Slater.
Like Star-Lord, he flies around with a jetpack,
wields some kind of ray gun, and seems to
offer plenty of swagger and wit.
"Sorry I'm late.
It was happy hour."
However, unlike Star-Lord who spends much
of his screen-time acting in his own self
interest before coming through as the hero
in the end Maximus does the opposite, selfishly
attempting to save his own skin before getting
brutally slain for his efforts.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.